hello hmm and welcome to this video I
have got sound yes somewhat in doubt you
will check now okay so let's see what we
get modern more annoys maybe that reply
plate this in a recent game which I
think never made it on the channels was
one of those silent games you should do
I can't take a five
Joe seven let's all play on this Bishop
to I'm this line with Bishop to before
check it's quite quite a decent way to
play a less theoretically explored
position this is just not as well
explored as main lines and it is quite
playable I think why does a bit better
here but it's shouldn't be terrible yeah
I expect white to play either Eve for e3
or this one yeah this is actually
interesting you have to be a little bit
circumspect iam and I'd have six he
might take play Queen g5 and then her
two ports I could be an issue
97 looks passive though maybe I can do
this first
I'm not enthusiastic about this I mean I
wanted to play something a little bit
less theoretically explored but
sometimes you rather quickly figure out
why it is theoretically less explored
simply because it is not so great
so let's see what's going on here yeah
if I take I'm absolutely yeah well it's
not so bad I was a bit afraid of eat
eggs
but it's not so bad so I got castled and
I mean this should be basically okay a
pieces are if I know you just wants to
trade okay I've got a good square on c5
it's interesting here maybe to think
about Knight to a4 but just preventing
95 yeah he's going for it
yeah I could eat for but if I Knight to
e5
I'm a little bit uncertain about this
hmm maybe maybe this first then he
formed I had an idea but no of it works
when the sisters this looks okay now if
a good night Sharad 95 is good
[Music]
yeah I'm uncertain him I got a couple of
things I could have played b5 as well I
mean I don't think it was great but it
was something to check at least and here
I'm really uncertain about things and
we're gonna find you or not I don't
really know the pony for looks a bit
exposed sorry
hmm yeah might just take this this thing
on your form if Knight takes e4 at the
end okay I should speed up 30 seconds
not great I'm not great at all yeah I
didn't think that this is so dangerous
maybe I'm wrong but if you just if he
takes now nothing happens and I don't I
don't know OOP tea for me maybe it's
slightly better for white wood before
it's not something that I mean would
scare me all that much
yeah I think here yeah covered is seven
and make sure that Bishop age seven g6
is okay for me 95 it's always F form
somehow yeah I'd like to get rookie aid
and so let's try
he can go rupee for if he just wants to
make a draw it's not easy to to prevent
maybe I can do that I mean if you trade
takes f7 king of six root t2 will be
okay I'm fairly certain
[Music]
I should have enough play there when the
queenside
the bishop is not doing that much okay
yeah we could gah yeah I'm not sure I
mean it just I feel like I'm quite
active with the King coming coming to to
the center of course the bishop should
is supposed to be better in such a
position but I'm not sure that this
applies I had a somewhat similar type of
ending with the bishop who while ago and
I was really overestimating my chances
there it's it's worth something that I'm
on the fifth rank against the third
maybe he's going to play him a three
and the bells are ringing
could run all the way there it's very
interesting actually because this is
totally dominating he cannot really do
much
and now if I can go to d4 it would be
excellent
I mean his point is worth noting here
maybes dominating my bishop somehow and
my knight somehow
hmm things get tricky you know very
tricky that was weird
a little bit that all of a sudden I was
better than I ever really was I think
the final position could be could be
lost don't really see what is movers
yeah okay
will who would seem yeah I wasn't happy
with all this let me just bet
church bells on the whole time yeah it's
I think this position must be a little
bit better for why it's 90 match five is
not a bad idea by the engine intending
to use the square but I'm interested in
the game I was expecting me takes the
engine wants to do that so this is a
little bit more testing I believe with
Luke here and effort to combat I thought
if I move the Queen away and it must be
someone okay so castles and a5 yeah
maybe this wasn't most precise I mean
Knight a four was a little bit annoying
I asked him if this is this is making a
lot of sense this is good then you
attack him this is not great
and after b3 1k of rooks gets ready and
if I can trade one pair of rooks I'm
fine
because then King to g7 King to e7 will
always simply cover all the entry
squares and I can play from there the
position is equal if you give me the
choice I'd rather be black because there
is a little bit of a tendency that this
Bishop might not be the most active
piece because of the symmetry here and
there are some pawns on light squares
it's silly but just black is a bit more
it's easier to imagine how black can do
something at least yeah I played a5 and
94 was good yeah now it's just a little
bit a little bit uncomfortable
I decided to play for and ninety five
and maybe three King f8 yeah not not
great rookie for now is strong yeah
didn't see that one just attacking it
once more if I go III that's always just
f4 and my knight here only has a very
silly square I in fact the engine finds
Knight d7 which is extremely strong and
once you see it once you spot it this is
going to be very strong I lose one look
for the bishop and then at the end those
Knights have absolutely no wood outposts
and deck pawns will run you know the
game move I think is makes it very easy
for me after that I don't think I have a
problem now yeah not to b6 and the
engine gives white a slight edge which I
don't think this is can be much of
anything I'm close to the center Oh
before is interested man that's really
interesting before a 45
that's a move that I should have seen
maybe Luca aid is a clever idea by the
engine simply anticipating that this is
now going to hang and now you can move
the line to a form but this is extremely
tough to play with a group a okay Bishop
f3 key is 7 he could have gone before
and now I think I should be ok critical
now is still there the pawn draft like
this this and he I wanted to go King f6
and I thought ok this is going to happen
next and what's the deal
yeah he's got Luke age 5 though which is
an argument in favor of playing g6 and
setup King f6 so g6 then I get him a
computer does not believe it's full
compensation so King G to look T to h4
tending h5 probably I need to spend the
investor move here like this in order to
play 95i h5 yeah white is for choice -
for choice that was critical clearly
after Luke deform I'm completely okay
yeah this is a little bit easier food
like this and a my king is quicker but
again it's it's very draw action should
end in a draw I think it got got two
problems got problematic when he played
King c2 King do three has to be played
now now I'm a lot better Kim Knight f6
or king before and then Knight c5 is
even stronger but okay this is still not
a bad idea
I Scott King III ah this is why Knight
f6 is less precise and with the problem
was that I played this and only now I
did a spot how strong King before
actually is now that move wins but it I
only spotted it here that now I have
this dominating position yeah and now I
94 Wow
my chief was winning that's fascinating
how exactly king did - and then you go a
five and six one oh wow yeah white gets
it gets we kind of saw one coming and I
will either win this or this huh
okay I was playing 97 but I think I'm
probably it wins anyway yeah the engine
is so on giving me a winning position I
think it should be winning even with
this snow approach it's just like he
plays without the King and they cannot
sustain that yeah yeah there's nothing
no choice something like that it's just
a winning ending yeah interesting
endgame okay guys thanks for watching